[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICOLAS ROARD: All right.
So good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Nicolas.
I'm the tech lead for
Android Studio Design
tools and the
ConstraintLayout library.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So you might have noticed,
we released a really cool
navigation editor.
We are not going to
talk about that today.
But there was a
session this morning.
It's on YouTube.
Check it out.
There's code labs.
It's really cool.
So we are going to
talk about the layout
editor, the work
we've been working on,
the entire team this past
year, the improvements we made.
Specifically we will focus on
sample data, which is something
really cool we shipped in 3.2.
And we'll also talk about
ConstraintLayout 2.0
and what's coming up
with these libraries.
For first, for the section
on the layout editor,
Vadim and Diego are
going to present you.
VADIM CAEN: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
So, to start with, we're
going to talk about the layout
editor.
Most of you are probably
quite familiar with the tool.
So it's a graphical
tool that enables
you to build your layout
without having to write any XML.
And it's supposed to
make you more productive.
So what is nice with
the layout editor
is that it also works
with your custom views.
So if in your code,
you have a custom view,
it will render in
the layout editor.
And the nice thing is that any
custom view from your project
will appear in the palette.
So our goal is really to
make you more productive.
So we've added some nice
features this year to do so.
The first one I want to talk
about is the conversion.
So if you right
click on a view, you
will see the Convert View option
that will make this pop up
appear.
And you will be able to select
one of the pre-set components,
or you can use
the edit text just
to pick any view
from your project.
And this view is contextual.
So if you right click on a
view which is not a view group,
we will show some pre-set
of non-view group views.
The next thing I
want to talk about
is a navigation between include
layout and their parent.
So in the component
tree or in the preview,
if you double click on a
component on an include tag,
it will jump automatically
to the children.
And if you click on the arrow on
the top of the component tree,
it will jump back to the parent.
This is quite handy to go
fast between two layouts.
The layout editor
is really powerful
used with ConstraintLayout.
And ConstraintLayout
is a great layout
because it's very powerful.
But it's very verbose, right?
So you might not want to
write all your XML by hand.
So what you should
do instead is take
advantage of all the menus
we have in the layout editor
to generate this XML for you.
So again, right click on a view.
And then you can use the align--
any of the top option
to choose your option.
And we have many of them.
So feel free to check
them after this session.
And really it's going to
make you more productive.
But most of you are probably
populating your layout
at runtime.
You have data from the internet
and you want to pre-play them.
So they are not rendering
in the layout editor all.
So to solve this
issue, Diego is going
to come here and talk
about the sample data.
DIEGO PEREZ: Thanks, Vadim.
So before we talk about sample
data, let's talk about tools
attributes.
So the tools attributes
are the XML attributes.
Now, you actually used to
give additional information
to the Android studio
under the layout editor.
You are probably familiar
with many of them.
We are not going to
talk about all of them.
Let's cover one example
just to be clear on this.
So you probably have seen this.
So in your strings file,
you get a lead warning
saying that you haven't
translated a particular string.
Usually what you want to
do is to fix this error,
you translate it.
That's it.
The error is gone.
But there might be
valid reasons why
you don't want to translate
actually this string.
It could be, that is the
name of the application
and you don't want to translate
it in every single language.
Only in certain languages.
So what you can do
here is you basically
can tell Android Studio,
look, I know about this error.
But I don't want you to tell
me about it because it's fine.
So that is one example.
There are many others.
But what we want
to talk about now
is actually design
time attributes.
This is just a
subset of the tools
attributes that I talked about.
They are giving additional
information and context
to the layout editor.
So let's see with one example.
So in this case, what we have
is, we created our toolbar.
We had to keep the
lay out on its own.
So we use ConstraintLayout.
We created it.
And this is how it will
look in the layout editor.
So what you can see is the
toolbar without any context.
So you can see the
layout, but you
don't know how
it's going to look
at runtime in your application.
So there is something
that we can do.
You can again tell
the layout editor,
this layout is going to be
included in this other layout
that I'm hinting here.
So using these
attribute tools showing,
we are letting the
layout editor know
that we want to embed this
heather into the main layout.
And that way, we can
see it in context.
So now when we are editing,
we know if the colors match.
We can actually tweak our
design and see how every change
impacts our layout.
And the best thing is,
again, you can do it.
You can edit it right there.
You don't have to sit
with a blank space
or anything like that.
So let's see another interesting
use of design time attributes.
When you have a text view,
this is usually what you get.
So you have hello world.
And that's it.
But you can tell to
the layout editor
that you know that this text
view is going to look slightly
different at runtime.
And you do that by again
using the tools namespace.
So in this case,
what we are doing is
we are replacing both the
text and the text color.
And we are telling the
layout editor, at runtime,
this is going to look different.
And we are about to see
how this is very useful.
Let's go with a slightly
more complicated example.
When you have a
recycler view, this
is what you get by default.
It takes the space.
You can see how the recycler
view is going to be laid out.
But it's not very useful.
It doesn't help you
to actually come up
with a good design for it.
It's just a list of elements
with a lot of empty space.
So again, we can use the tools
attributes to basically let
the layout editor know,
this is that the layout
that I'm going to use.
So you have probably seen
already list item many times.
Very simple.
You just say it.
But we can do other things.
We can tell the
layout editor, OK,
how is this going to
look with five elements?
All these things, you usually
cannot do them in the layout
editor, because these are
things that happen at runtime.
So usually the source of
information for our recycler
view is an adapter.
So the adapter might depend
on network, on database,
on many things that we don't
have available at design time.
So doing this, you
give us context.
And then the layout editor
will render correctly,
similar to what you
have at runtime.
So let's now go
into sample data.
So sample data is a feature
that we introduced in 3.0.
And what it does is it helps
you to actually populate
data that is not
available at design time.
So in this case,
what we are doing
is telling the
layout editor that I
want to use the tint property.
And I want to get the data
from this data source,
which we call
@sample/material_colors.
And that data source is
simply a file, a plain file,
with a list of colors
that you see there.
So what happens at design
time is the layout editor
will get a different
color for every item.
So that looks better.
But we can do more.
So let's see how you
create that file.
You got to your project,
new, sample data directory.
And that is how we create
the directory where
we are going to put every
data source that we have.
In our case, we want to
create material colors.
So new file.
And then we name
it material_colors.
And we put the list of colors.
And that's it.
It's that simple.
Now you can use it
in any property.
In this case, tint.
So this is one of the
types of data sources
that you can use in sample data.
So it's basically
a list of colors.
You can have lists
of any kind that you
want, like regular text.
And you just replace
it in your text field.
But you can have other
things more interesting.
Like you can have dimensions.
So if you have dimensions,
using the tools attributes,
you can tell the layout editor,
I want to use this dimension.
And I want it to be
different for every item.
And you can do that
using sample data.
We also have other
types of data sources.
You can have images.
You create them in
a very similar way.
What you do is, you
create, instead of a file,
you create a directory.
And then you drop all
your images in there.
And then recycler view
will get a different image
for every item.
So it's very simple.
And the last type that I
want to tell you about this
is JSON files.
So JSON files is a
similar way to the list
that we have before.
But it allows you to do
something that you cannot do
with lists.
You can have all your data
together in one place.
You can add, maybe,
context about why
a particular item is like that.
Or you can even get a
sample from your dead API
and put it into the sample data.
In this case, what we
have is a list of notes.
So what you can see is we have
a title and we have [INAUDIBLE]
And the way that you
use this in sample data,
is you can reference any
of those leaf elements.
Let's see how to do that.
So in this case, what we are
telling the layout editor is,
I want you to replace
text at design time.
And I want you to do it with
@sample/ the name of the JSON
file, and then the note
that we saw before.
So in this case, we are doing
it with title and author.
Remember that this
will change depending
on the name of the JSON file.
It doesn't even need
to be called JSON.
If you don't want to provide
your own data sources,
Android Studio
will also provide.
It already comes with a
set of predefined ones.
So you don't have
to create your own.
We give you a set of them.
We give you names.
We give you lorem
ipsum, obviously.
And we also give
you a set of images.
For example, you
can use avatars.
And you don't even
need to create images.
You can just use the
ones that we give you.
And again, how to use
that is very similar.
The only difference
that you can see here
is we added tools as the
namespace of the data source.
So instead of being @sample,
now it's @tools:sample.
So using syntax completion, you
can see all the different data
sources that we have.
But in 3.2., we added
new features in order
to help you to use this.
So everything that we saw
was already available in 3.0.
And in 3.2 we are
adding a few things
that Vadim is going
to tell you about,
to help you using sample data.
VADIM CAEN: Sample
data is a great tool.
But we love tools.
And so we decided to
put a UI on top of it.
So what does it look like?
I'm sure most of you
already did that.
So you have an image view.
You're taking it
from the palette.
And the resource
picker will pop up.
And since you've just
started your project,
you have only the
launcher icon available.
So you use it.
And your preview doesn't
look really great.
So what you can do instead
now, in the resource picker,
you have the simple
data category,
and you can pick
any resource data
from your project or
the pre-defined one.
So now our image
view looks better.
And we can see every instance
of it in our recycler view.
But if you want to make some
change to this sample data?
What if I just want to use
one single image from my set?
So we've introduced in Android
Studio 3.2, the new design time
helper that you can access
by clicking the wrench icon
right below the image view.
So here, I'm going to
uncheck view as a set.
And this will give
me the ability
to select only one
image from my set.
And I can try it out with
any image from the set.
But now, let's say that we do
want to give it another look.
And we want to pick images
from another data set.
So we can just use
the drop down button
and select another data set.
And here we go.
Our recycler view
has a brand new look.
So it's very nice
to preview what
it would look like with
different kinds of images.
So you can always jump
back to the resource picker
and have the full
set of resources
available by clicking the browse
button on the bottom of the pop
up.
And the same options
are available.
And also I wanted to mention
that if you select a sample
data on the resource
picker, it will populate
the design time attributes.
It will be removed at runtime.
We have the same design
time helper for text view.
So here for example, I'm just
selecting a different set
for each text view.
And as you can see
on the recycler view,
each item is taking one instance
of its own set for each item.
And finally, we've also added
this feature for recycler view.
And this is quite nice.
You can browse between all the
templates we provide for you.
And the file will be
automatically created.
So you can just jump
back to the credit file
and preview your changes.
And all the design
time attributes
are automatically populated.
So you don't have to do
anything to preview it and take
full advantage of sample data.
But the layout editor
is even more powerful
if you use it with
ConstraintLayout.
So Nicolas is going
to come on stage
and do a deep dive
into ConstraintLayout.
NICOLAS ROARD: We released
ConstraintLayout officially
from the stable
version last year.
We announced it a
couple of years ago.
So if you don't
know about it, it's
a library that allows you to
easily create user interfaces.
And we tried to
encourage you to use
flat hierarchies, which come
in very handy for animations.
It's a support library.
It's compatible
essentially everywhere.
It's small.
And you're in full
control on when you ship
with a specific versoin or not.
It comes with a great UI builder
that we have in Android Studio.
And essentially,
please try to use it.
It's something we're
working really hard on
to make your life easier.
So we released
ConstraintLayout 1.0 last year
with a bunch of capabilities.
You can set up
your UI by creating
relations between elements.
There is a lot of
capabilities here--
related positioning, center,
et cetera, et cetera.
And there is some helper
objects like guidelines
to help you set up your screen.
So it's already a very
full set of features
But a month ago, we released
ConstraintLayout 1.1,
which added a lot of
bug fixes, performance
improvements, new features, new
ways of expressing your layout.
And I'm just going to
highlight one that you actually
see on the slides,
the barrier, which
allows you to
position an element
relative to a set of elements.
So whatever the position and
dimension of those elements,
that element on the right is
going to position correctly.
So essentially, with
ConstraintLayout 1.1,
we have a really
flexible layout,
something that
should essentially
let you express any UI.
And you can just add
it to your project
by using normal
gradual dependency.
We are now shipping
on Maven so it
should be very easy
for you to use it
in your build server, et cetera.
But I think a lot
of you here are
in this room to hear me talk
about ConstraintLayout 2.0.
So with ConstraintLayout
2.0, we are starting
with ConstraintLayout 1.
And ConstraintLayout
1 is a great base.
As I said, it gives
the entire flexibility
that you need to create your UI.
And it comes with
the UI builder.
And one of the concepts
that we introduced
in ConstraintLayout 1 was the
concept of helper objects--
objects that, even though
you can manipulate them
in the UI builder, they do
not appear on your screen
when you run the application,
but essentially they
help you create your UI.
So one of them is
the guideline object.
You know, if your
designer typically
specifies a UI with
horizontal lines,
et cetera, well, you can simply
replicate those in your UI.
So it's a lot easier for
you to set up your screen.
Similarly, with 1.1, we have
the barrier I just talked about.
And what's nice with
those helper objects,
is that we do have some support
for them in the UI builder.
So you can simply manipulate
them and add the elements
to those helper objects
in the component tree
by dragging elements into them.
Something you might not realize
is that those objects are not
view groups.
They only keep a
reference to the views.
So we still keep the
entire view tree very flat.
But because they
are just references,
we can have one object being
referenced in multiple helpers.
And that's starting to be
very interesting for us.
And you can think
about the helpers
as a way of keeping a
reference to a bunch of views.
You can still get
a flat hierarchy.
And the way we think about
it is that a helper gives you
a way of encapsulating
a behavior.
In 2.0, we are going to expose
those helpers as a constraint
[INAUDIBLE] class.
So you would be able to
create your own helpers.
And if you have your own
helpers in your project,
similar to what we
have with custom views,
they will be present
in Android Studio.
So you'll be able to
manipulate your own objects.
We kind of highlighted
three broad categories
for the helpers in 2.0.
One category is layout
manipulation-- helpers
that are going to help
you create a layout.
Another one is helpers
that will apply something
after the layout has been done.
So kind of post-layout.
And finally, we
have some helpers--
because helpers are views,
can be views as well--
helpers that we can use to
do some specific rendering,
specific display.
For the virtual layouts,
this is one of the concepts
that we are really keen on.
The idea is that
the helper is going
to set the constraints for you.
The simplest example I can
think of is a linear helper.
You know, if you created a chain
in ConstraintLayout 1, well,
that will allow you to do
exactly the same thing.
But you will manipulate it a
little bit like linear lay out,
for instance.
The only difference is that
you have all the features
that chain provides you.
And the way you use
them, it's very easy.
It's a normal view.
You can constrain
that view itself.
But the only thing you need to
care here is that list of IDs
that you reference.
We have another virtual
layout that we launched
with 2.0, which essentially
implements the FlexboxLayout
semantics.
So those objects
are pretty useful.
But at the same time, I
think, pretty expected.
But while we were
developing those helpers
we came up with
additional use cases.
So one example of a post layout
object is a flying object.
Let's say that you want your
objects on the first layout
to fly in.
Well, you could simply reference
this object with the flying
decorator and that's all.
So no code.
It's purely declarative.
You just add that to your XML
file, reference that object,
and it will animate
on first launch.
We have another object
that's very powerful.
Layers allows you
essentially a lot of things.
It kind of allows you to
consider a set of views
and apply operation to them.
So there's a bunch of graphical
operation that you can apply.
And we will do the
math behind the scenes
to apply them correctly.
You can also set
it up so that it
takes by default the bounds of
the views that it references.
And you can use it to set
up a background very easily
in that way.
And those are use
cases that we will
expose is, you could use the
layer a little bit like you
would use layers in
graphical photo editors
to have a bunch of layers
to specify your elements.
And when you are OK with
those elements' constraints,
you could lock that
layer and be sure to not
inadvertently modify them.
So it's a very powerful helper.
Here's a quick example
on how it would
look like by drawing a
background around a bunch
of buttons being referenced.
And without having to set
up the constraints manually,
I can easily surround those
objects with a background.
And just to prove you that
we are still with a flat view
tree, we can apply
this operation
that I'm talking about and
everything will just follow.
But the background
will stay where it is.
So it's a silly example.
It's just to show you the
potential of those objects.
Another useful decorator
is a circular reveal.
And it actually
does what it says.
And it's the typical
effect that you've
been familiar with
with material design.
And if I press the
button that's better.
The interesting thing
here is that you'll
notice that it only applies
to the element referenced.
So we have this row of buttons
that are not referenced.
And so the circular reveal
did not apply to them.
And if you played
with circular reveal,
you'd see that it's actually
a bit tricky to do that.
The interesting
thing here as well
is that we are not creating
our own circular reveal.
We are just using the
normal circular reveal.
But essentially, we
package it in a way
that makes it a lot easier
for you to play with and use
in your layouts.
So on that same idea,
we have decorators
that are helpers that
are here to draw things.
And same things with
reference views.
And you can draw
something with it.
So that's probably
a little confusing
in terms of what type of
effect you can get with that.
So let me show you.
So you may want an
effect like that.
You know, kind of
a lava lamp effect
with those blobs moving around.
And what you'll see is that
the result of that effect
will depend on the
position of those blobs.
But the final rendering has to
take in account all of them.
And that would normally
be a very difficult effect
to achieve.
So the way it
works with helpers,
so that you can think
about it that way--
you have a canvas, right,
like what you paint on.
You'll have,
actually, some image
views that are essentially
sitting on top of that.
And they are normal image views.
So you lose nothing here.
They are normal views.
Normal widgets.
You can apply the usual things.
But we put their background
to be transparent.
And then we use a decorator
to draw the background.
And you can easily get
an effect like that.
You know, for instance.
A little slower.
There you go.
And just to show you
the bounds are correct,
we still have our image views.
Another type of decorator that
you can use in your project
is the bottom panel decorator.
So let's say that you have
a layout like that you may
have created by using a chain.
Very easy.
But if you'd like to set a
background on those objects,
and maybe change the colors.
So you can simply
apply this decorator,
reference those elements, and
we'll do the rest of the work.
And because, well, we can do a
little more interesting stuff
here, I can show you what
it may look like when
you click on those buttons.
So just to give you an
idea of the type of effects
you can get with decorators.
So I'm clicking on this.
My menu comes in.
I can press that.
Some other menu comes in.
I press it.
And there's a circular reveal.
It's of course a very silly UI.
But it's just to give you
an idea of what you can do.
What's very interesting here
is that if you look at it
in studio, and you know, if
I zoom on the component tree,
you'll notice that actually,
we mostly have just views.
And just a bunch of helpers.
There's actually no code here.
So I think it's really a
useful addition to your toolset
as a programmer to
try to really separate
the fill with the actual
data and your actual behavior
on your application.
So to summarize
with the helpers,
you can tag your own views
with those, essentially.
You can encapsulate
and reuse the behavior,
and it's all declarative.
Let me talk briefly
about layout management.
So you've been probably
playing with constraint sets
on the ConstraintLayout 1.1,
which is a way of encapsulating
an entire state for a layout.
And if you switch between
two of those states,
you can animate them.
So that's very nice.
But you know, initializing those
things is a little cumbersome.
You have to create your layout,
load those layouts manually,
et cetera.
So in 2.0, we'll have
a separate XML file
that lets you specify states.
Because essentially
that's what they are.
I have a layout.
That layout has different
representations,
different states.
And you can associate that
with different layouts.
So the way you would
use them is simply
by coding [INAUDIBLE]
description
and we'll do the
rest of the job.
You can then switch
states simply
by coding set states
with the state ID.
And that's it.
One nice thing is that
you can specify a region
on when a specific constraint
set is going to be applied.
And by plugging that into
onConfigurationChanged--
and I'm showing that
on a Chromebook--
you'll see that
automatically, depending
on the size of the window,
we'll switch layouts.
So it's a very easy
way for you to have
different behavior for layouts.
If you want a little
more fancy, you
can, on the preLayoutChange,
plug a TransitionManager,
and then we will animate
the layout transition.
So I think with devices
like Chromebooks,
that's the type of
use case that's going
to be more and more useful.
And that's essentially
Layout Management.
So to quickly recap on
ConstraintLayout 2 so far,
we have the helpers API.
We have those virtual
layouts and decorators.
We have the resize API.
We also have other stuff
I haven't talked about,
like a new [INAUDIBLE]
API for manipulating
the constraints directly.
And we have motion layouts.
And to talk about
motion layouts,
I'm really happy
to introduce John.
JOHN HOFORD: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, I'm really excited to
show you guys MotionLayout.
It's a brand new layout
that we're introducing
with ConstraintLayout 2.2.
So let's kind of get into it.
It starts off with a
subclass of ConstraintLayout
called MotionLayout.
It's a layout.
It has all the properties
of ConstraintLayout.
But the whole trick
with animating
between two constraint sets--
that will be done for
you by MotionLayout.
So if you have two
constraint sets,
it will switch between them and
animate between them by itself.
But you'll notice, because
it's a ConstraintLayout,
you can actually use the
helpers that were shown there.
But it also provides
you with the ability
to edit the custom
attributes of the system.
So you'll notice the
blue light there.
It's changing because it's a
custom attribute in the system.
So constrained sets now can
handle custom attributes.
It allows you to
animate anything.
One of the other
things that it does
is it allows you to
control on touch directly.
So it'll manage
your touch events
by tracking your
velocity of your finger
and matching it to the velocity
of views in the system,
and naturally give you a
smooth transition between them
via touch.
We also support helpers because
it's just a ConstraintLayout.
So the helpers
Nicolas just showed--
they're there too.
And they can work
together and apart.
Now let's change the
transition a little bit.
We want to move the i into
the middle of the screen.
But if we look closely, there's
a bit of a problem here.
You see the arrow
clashes with the i.
We'll have to fix that.
And the way we do that is a
feature we call keyframes.
Essentially, if we have a
beginning and an end of a path,
we can distort the path
by adding a keyframe.
And once we add the
keyframe, it will avoid
the path, which is pretty cool.
So now we have a motion scene.
It has constraint sets.
It has on touch keyframes,
custom attributes.
With a little flag
on your device,
you can see the path of all
the objects you've set in it.
So you can understand
what all your views
are doing on the device.
So one of the nice things
that we've supported in it
is nesting of constrained
sets of MotionLayouts.
So in this particular
example, we
have two views being
animated by a third view.
They're both constraint
MotionLayouts.
Layouts.
And they're both being driven
by a third MotionLayout.
The top view is just
doing a fade to black.
But you'll notice something
else in that view.
This is an animated view that
was custom written by Nicolas
that is being driven by
MotionLayout because it
implements an
on-progress method.
So you can drive your own
custom animations directly
from MotionLayout.
So one of the things
it's really good at
is synchronizing motions.
Anything that's very complex,
sequences of many things moving
on the screen, it
will handle it,
and will also allow you to
interact with the touch.
So we added one more
thing to the system,
something we call cycles.
This is the ability to build
into the keyframes oscillatory
behaviors.
It can vibrate and
shake in various ways.
And you might wonder, OK, what
do we do with these KeyCycles?
So in this particular
example, first,
let me just unfold them
with a staggered effect.
But now I can take
one and have it
roll because it's oscillated.
Or I can do a different effect.
I could have it sort of
bounce along the edge.
I got bored and I just had
that one flying around.
Another typical
example, is you put it
like doing a little
shake at the end.
So now one of the cool
things is, we build editors.
So we're building an
editor for that thing.
And we call it
the Motion Editor.
It's part of the design surface.
But now, you'll be able
to do those edits directly
in the design surface.
So kind of, to take
you through how
you would do that in
the design surface,
based on
ConstraintLayout, you just
create your constraints for
your first constraint set,
switch to the second,
edit the constraints
for the second constraint set.
And then once you do
that, if you hit play,
it will show you the animation
between those two constraint
sets.
There's a checkbox to
enable showing you the path.
So now you could see the path.
But how would you
add a KeyFrame?
Well, you just position the
cursor where you want it.
You add the type of KeyFrame
that you want to add.
And you can just
distort the position
by selecting the KeyFrame and
moving it around on the screen.
And let's just do that one
more time so you can see it.
Just select a position--
any position--
create a KeyFrame.
And then we just move it.
So here is much more
complex motions.
They're all being animated.
This one has quite a
few KeyFrames in it,
just designed to allow
you to set transparency
on some things, change
the size of other things,
move them around.
But it all works in the IDE.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLAS ROARD: So
one last thing.
You probably are eager
to try all those things.
So, a lot of that
is actually in 3.2.
All the sample data
we have showed you,
are the current integration
with ConstraintLayout 1.1.
Go, download 3.2.
Try it out.
We release the [INAUDIBLE]
13 this Tuesday.
So please give it a try.
ConstraintLayout 2, the
library with MotionLayout--
we are talking about releasing
it in a few days, hopefully.
And Motion Editor--
it's an ongoing work.
But we are really
excited about it.
So think about it.
There are code labs for
the navigation editor
as well, for the Chrome
resize API we showed you.
We also want to hear
from you in general.
We are easily reachable,
the four of us.
But for this particular
session, there
is a feedback you can fill.
We also are going to
have an office hour
this afternoon
after this session.
So please come see us.
And that completes our talk.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]